we were in a great discussion about the
Ukraine war
um because we spent eight trillion
dollars on Wars we've spent all of these
all of these interventions that we had
after 9 11 where all of these The
Architects of them these
neoconservatives after that you know
they were shut out of government right
they kind of laughed they were disgraced
and now they're popping up again they're
popping up again as Democrats and they
are the main a lot of them are uh some
of the main uh promoters of the idea of
this endless war in the Ukraine yeah and
I mean that's one of my
one of the things my uncle figured out
when he uh four months into his
administration you know he had been
warned by Eisenhower about the emergence
of the military industrial complex which
would turn America into an imperial
State abroad
and a surveillance day to Garrison State
a Security State at home and you know
Eisenhower had said the thing that our
our founding fathers had said
you cannot maintain democracy if you're
an imperial site abroad you're gonna you
know you'll bankrupt the middle class
you'll
you'll turn us into a surveillance day
my uncle for my zen recognized that you
know when he was lied to by the CIA by
Alan Dulles Charles Richard Bissell and
by the military brass about the pigs
and when the men were dying on the beach
you know he took public blame for it but
he privately told his aides I want to
take the CIA shattered into a thousand
pieces and Scatter it to the winds
and um and then he fired Alan Dulles
Richard Bissell and Charles Cabell the
guys who were directly responsible for
long term but for the next thousand days
of his administration he was in a
pitched battle
to keep our country out of War they
wanted the wars because that was that he
recognized that their job had devolved
into providing the military-industrial
complex military contractors a constant
pipeline of new ores to feed their
profits well
and you know the neocons uh which are
neo-conservatives for people who don't
know it's a movement that started in uh
early 1990s around 92 when the
when the Berlin Wall came down and they
published a document that called the
project for New American Century that
said that because we were the Victor in
the cold war that America now had
the uh the the right to rule the world
uh for a century or more at by using its
Superior military Powers the unit power
so after 2001 we spent between then and
now we've spent eight trillion dollars
on Wars on regime change Wars it was
Iraq war and then all these spillover
wars
in Yemen Libya Syria uh Pakistan
Afghanistan
Etc what did we get for those Wars
here's what we got Iran Iraq is now
worse off than we found it it's an
incoherent kind of battle between Shia
and Sunni death squads
we killed more Iraqis than Saddam
Hussein
we pushed we killed between 650 000 a
million Iraqis
we
have pushed Iraq into a proxy posture
with Iran which is exactly the foreign
policy outcome we've been trying to
avoid for decades uh we in the spillover
were in Syria we created Isis
we sent two million refugees into Europe
and destabilize every democracy in
Europe you know we we created brexit
right the riots that are now happening
in France are direct result of that
those Wars
and we bankrupt the American middle
class because we didn't have the money
to pay for them so and that is you know
we got it and then we're given these
kind of comic book depictions
each time you know whether it's Gaddafi
whether it's a Saddam or given this
this caricature of you know okay there's
a bad guy here and there's a good guy
we're the good guys we're always the
good guys and here's the bad guy and
it's a
it's a black and white debate there is
no question about it if you side with
the bad guy if you question ask
questions about you know the action
it means you're on the side of Putin or
something right right and that that
whole game
so
um the the what happened I mean the
thing people should know about Ukraine
war we were told it's you know Putin
wants to be the new Hitler he wants to
invade Europe and right right and but
when you look at what actually happened
it's much more complex than that and
much more nuanced
Putin actually steadfastly resisted
going to war he's he has said and the
Russians not just Putin but all the
Russian leaderships had said since 1992.
if you move NATO to the east you're
going to provoke a violent response we
we you know
Russia's been invaded three times
through Ukraine
the last time Hitler killed one out of
every seven Russians so they they you
know it's a national security priority
for them
at Ukraine cannot be under the control
of a hostile foreign power they can't
tolerate that and all of our greatest
diplomats George Cannon who was the
architect of the
containment policy after World War II
have constantly reiterated that if you
go into Ukraine with NATO you're going
to force Russians to have the violent
response
also I here's what happened in 2014
we put five billion dollars
into the med on into funding the Madonna
Rebellion which is this you know
Uprising in Ukraine against
the duly elected governments of the
Ukraine which was neutral and maybe
leaned a little towards Russia but we
wanted them out and we paid five billion
dollars to in a in a series of
demonstrations that ended in a coup
d'etat against that regime
and the installation of a pro-american
regime
Putin wants to settle things immediately
the first thing that new pro-american
regime did was it made it illegal to
speak the Russian language in Damas and
luigons and it um banned Russian
political parties too right yes yeah and
when the when Russian ethnic Russians
which are 90 of that population when
they began peaceful demonstrations they
were attacked violently and ultimately
they it started a civil war 14 000 were
killed the Civil War really began in
2014. Russia
tried to sell it the people of those
provinces voted
to join the Russian Union right and and
Putin said no
so this is not consistent with the
portrait of him
and then he said we need a peace treaty
that protects these people I don't want
to go in there but we need a peace
treaty and he agreed he negotiated with
France Germany England and
um and the U and Ukraine
on a peace treaty to organize a pastry
called the minska courts that would have
left
part of Ukraine as a semi-autonomous
region able to speak their own language
and that would have permanently kept
NATO out of Ukraine it was a reasonable
settlement
um
zielinski who's a comedian and an actor
campaigns in 2019 and wins he has no
political experience but he wins in a
landslide 70 of ukrainians support him
why he went on one issue peace
he said I'm going to sign the Minx
Accords and I'm going to get a ratified
in the Ukrainian Parliament Ukrainian
people did not want a war they wanted
peace
he gets in there and suddenly he pivots
now why did he pivot nobody knows but I
think it's fair gas that he pivoted for
two reasons one is that Ultra naturalist
in his government and he is battalion
um told him that they would kill him if
he negotiated a piece with Russia and
neocons particularly Victoria Newland in
the U.S White House and state department
told him the same thing that he could
not sign a piece of course so he
abandons it
Russia goes in Putin goes in but only
with 40 000 people
he's got a lot more he's got a million
1.2 million reserves but he only sends
40 000 people in there why
this is a nation of 44 million people
Ukraine oh merely he's not trying to
conquer Ukraine with 40 000 troops right
he wanted to bring us the negotiating
table so and this and this they come in
on January
in March almost nobody's been killed at
that point compared to what's happened
now
he says okay let's negotiate peace he
comes back to the negotiating table
and they if the U.S won't help them
oh he has to go to Israel and Turkey to
get their help negotiating a peace
Accord they negotiate a peace Accord
which is uh which is Minsk Accords 2.0
with Putin
lensky initials said the Russians
initial it and the Russians start
withdrawing their troops from Ukraine in
good faith
what happens then Biden
and Boris Johnson over there the UK
prime minister to torpedo that peace
agreement and uh
and he and the land Force allensky to
turn up and since then
four hundred thousand Ukrainian kids
have been killed on the front lines and
uh and you know all of those kids and
mothers and every one of those lives was
an unnecessary tragedy and you know you
know my son went over there and fought I
did not know that but I had either I had
heard something like that and that's
amazing
well he and I
disagreed with the war yeah you know I
have tremendous respect for him and he
believed what he was doing he had great
sympathy Ukrainian people which I share
with Cheryl and I share of course he and
we're never the ones
right and um that's a badass thing for
him to do it shows his character to go
over there and and fight with Ukrainian
people I mean we didn't know that he was
going yeah I would not help if Manhattan
Beach was invaded you know what I mean
like I wouldn't even do that so the idea
yeah I would tweet about it so sad the
ransacking of Manhattan Beach I would
not who cares
I'm unaffected but no that's that's an
amazing thing and what uh is is he still
there is he oh he's back but he was in
he fought in the car keep offensive he
was a
machines on Earth I mean you tell what
happened yeah I mean well he he
he
told us he was going somewhere but
wouldn't tell us where yeah um because
he said he didn't want us to be worried
yeah um this would qualify his worry
yeah and then so after he left of course
we were worried because you know if
somebody says don't worry right I'm
gonna be okay it's like
what well what are you doing right um
and then we started seeing some credit
card uh charges in Poland and we you
know put two and two together and right
but we couldn't reach him we couldn't we
couldn't communicate with him right it
was really it was very it was very
stressful so he was joined a special
forces
a unit he was uh in the Foreign Legion
Ukraine important Legion and he fought
in that offensive as a machine gunner
first the Drone operator which is the
most dangerous job because the Russians
can tell as soon as you turn on that
drone and then they and it's our
children they send artillery the
artillery kills anything within 300 feet
um and and then he became a machine
gunner and
um he uh and you know now he's back and
he's he just graduated law school so he
says thank God
but all I talked to him yesterday and
all of the people that he served with
have either been killed or are
hospitalized you know
it's it's it's terrible
um but you gave a great succinct
explanation I think a lot of people are
confused about
uh why we're not trying to negotiate a
settlement why we're not trying to force
peace talks why that isn't something
that we're requiring along with all of
these donations and or I mean all of the
funding and the Weaponry
um but I think you know it's it's pretty
clear to a lot of people that we may not
want peace talks that well and you know
there's people making a lot of money on
this and
um when you know we committed uh now 140
billion you know if if Iden gets the
extra 24 billion that he's looking for
oh but in March we opted to 113 billion
well the entire budget of EPA is 12
billion so that's all we've got for the
environment this country well we have 10
times at
or Ukraine and um you know we're having
crisis here yeah we have a lot of we
have millions of people in the US that
can't eat that don't have enough it has
a lot of problems 35 of America's
resources are not making enough to pay
for basic human needs and those people
are on the edge of becoming homeless and
it's a crisis
um well the entire budget for CDC is 12
million
when we got 10 times that again
when Mitch McConnell was asked in March
why are we in the um why are we in the
Ukraine why do we have enough money for
this where's the money coming from he
said don't worry about it
because that money's not really going to
Ukraine it's going to U.S military
contractors Raytheon General Dynamics
Boeing Lockheed
and you know so he admitted it it's just
a big money laundering scheme to the
military industrial complex and then if
you look
who do you think actually owns all of
those companies State Street Vanguard
BlackRock exactly yes now you see it all
goes back to that yeah they're they're
strip mining the wealth from the
American middle class and shifting it
upward
through all of these different
mechanisms they're literally control
everything so I mean and no one's
talking about this which is interesting
the Republicans aren't talking about it
the Democrats aren't talking about it
um you're the only candidate out there
kind of bringing up these issues in this
way